all right here now to reiax is governor
Mike Huckabee former 2016 presidential
candidate Fox News contributor RI gov
did Pelosi change or did the modern Dems
change her lauren let me just tell you
something i nearly lost it when you said
that Biden and Pelosi looked like
clients of visiting angels that's got to
be the funniest line I've heard in
several moment a sztyc and the answer is
I do think Nancy Pelosi is struggling to
try to maintain some order I mean she's
trying to herd green flies and I used
that term deliberately this is a real
tough spot for her but here's the thing
that I love about what the president has
done this week he is not allowing her to
go out there call him a criminal saying
he's committing crimes by covering
things up and then walk over to his
house and look him in the eye and
pretend that she wants to do some
legislation and he's calling her out
he's not playing this ridiculous DC
semantics game of saying the gentlelady
from California because there's nothing
gentle about the lady from California
governor here's a historian Doug
Brinkley elevating San Fran grand man on
a throne let's watch she's now a
historic speaker I'm this may be seen as
the Pelosi age in the Democratic Party
she is the glue keeping the whole
Washington scene together
I think the glue is lost it's sticky
there's something going on I mean the
Democrats have nothing right now the
Mullah report totally left them hanging
and so now they're like a bunch of kids
who are still looking for Easter eggs on
the 4th of July they just won't let this
go
and it's making them look more and more
ridiculous there was in fact a
conspiracy a cover-up and an attempted
coup but it wasn't conducted by
President Trump our candidate Trump it
was conducted by the highest levels of
the US government when Barack Obama was
president
when you had names like Brennan and
clapper and McCabe and Comey and struck
and Paige and or who were leading all
these institutions well they're worried
about this declassification governor
clearly these documents are going to be
declassified we'll see a lot more about
their origins of this investigation but
what the Papadopoulos and Mifsud and all
the characters this is going to be like
a James Patterson novel by the time it's
all over
well I they need to be worried because I
think what they found in Attorney
General Barr is a no-nonsense law guy he
believes in the rule of law believes
that although apply to everybody
including the president but the best
attempt after 35 million dollars 19
investigators 500 witnesses was that
they couldn't find anything that would
make Donald Trump be criminally liable
or even in any way liable and so now
they're just reduced to howling at the
moon and that's what they have been
reduced to it's frankly a little
embarrassing for and meanwhile we have
really important crises facing the
country at the border we need this us
MCA pass Trump said today Nancy doesn't
even understand the u.s. MCA she needs
to get up to snuff learn the blern what
the the new trade deal would do for the
country but she's not interested in that
they're interested in obstructing
resisting and appealing to the aoc base
of the Democrat Party but she you see
her struggling it's like an internal
struggle for irrelevance memory I don't
know it's like a combination of a lot of
things I'm not a psychologist I can't
unpack it but the intervention needs to
go the other way governor great to see
you as always tonight thanks so much you
bet I'm gonna call visting angels and
tell them to get over to our house right
away at your recommendation thank you
very much